okay happy Halloween what I want to do
today is share of you advice for
applying machine learning and you
probably allude to this before but um
yeah I think over the last several weeks
you've learned a lot about the mechanics
of how to build different learning
algorithms everything from the
aggression which is aggression as VMS
random forests is it neuro networks and
what I want to do today is share of you
some principles for helping you become
efficient at how you apply all of these
things to solve whatever application
problem you might want to work on um and
so a lot of today's materials I should
not have mathematical but there's also
some of the hardest material tests were
in this class to understand um it turns
out that when you give advice on how to
apply a learning algorithm such as you
know don't waste lots of time collecting
data unless you you you have confidence
is useful to actually spend all that
time it turns out when I say things like
that people you know this easy agree is
that of course you shouldn't waste time
collecting loss a day there unless you
have some confidence it's actually good
use your time that's a very easy thing
to agree with but the hard thing is when
you go home today and you're actually
working on your class project right to
apply the principles we talked about
today when you're actually on the ground
talking to your teammates saying alright
do we collect more data for our class
project now or not to make the right
judgment call for that to map the
concepts you learn today so when you're
actually in the hot seat you know making
a decision do we go and spend another
two days scraping data off the internet
or do goons tune this out tune this
parameters algorithm to actually make
those decisions it's actually it it
often takes a lot of careful thinking to
make the mapping from the principles we
talked about today and they prepare all
of you go yep that makes sense but they
actually do that when you're in the hot
seat making the decisions that that's
something that
we often take take some careful thought
I guess and I think you know for a long
time
positive machine learning have been an
art right we're you know we'll go
through these people that have been
doing it for 30 years and we say hey my
learning algorithm doesn't work you know
what do we do now and then they would
have some judgment or you go people to
ask me and for some reason because we've
done it for a long time we'll say oh
yeah get more dates or tune that
parameter or try a new network of big
hidden units and for some reason that
work and what I hope to do today is turn
that black magic that hot that that arts
into much of a science so that you can
much more systematic make these
decisions yourself rather than talk to
someone there's done this for 30 years
then that for some reason is able to
give you the good recommendations even
if you know but turn it from more of a
black art into a more of a systematic
engineering discipline um and and just a
one-note someone I wouldn't do today is
not the best approach for developing
novel machine or any research if you are
if your main goes to write research
papers some of what I'll say will apply
some others say will not apply but I'll
come back to that later but so most of
today is focus on how the hell you build
stuff that works right the build build
applications that work so the three key
ideas you see today are first is
Diagnostics for debugging learning
algorithms one thing you might not know
or actually if you work on a class
project maybe you know this already is
that when you implant to learning Alvin
for the first time it almost never works
right that is not the first time and so
what is it I still remember it was there
was a weekend about a year ago where I
implemented
softmax regression on my laptop and it
worked the first time and even to this
day I still remember that feeling of
surprise I know there's gotta be a bug
and I went in to try to find a bug and
there wasn't about it but it is so rare
Travie Algren works the first time I
still remember every year later and so
longer the workflow of developing
learning algorithms it actually feels
like a debugging workflow right and so
my hope you become systematic at that um
and two key ideas here about our
analysis innovative analysis so how to
analyze the air as you're learning
algorithm and also how to how to
understand was not working with error
analysis how long said what's working
which is ablative analysis and then
finally some philosophies and how the
get started or the machine learning
project such as your class project
okay so let's starts without discussing
debugging learning algorithms um so what
happens all the time is you have an idea
from machine learning application you
implement something and then it won't
work as well as you hoped and the key
question is what do you do next right
whenever I work on machine learning
algorithm that's actually most of my
workflow we usually have something
unfermented it's just not working that
well
and your ability to decide what to do
NYX has a huge impact on your efficiency
I think when when when I was a when I
was in undergrad at Carnegie Mellon
University I had a friend that would
debug their code by you know they write
a piece of code and then as always we
write Pisco initially always a bunch of
syntax errors right and so their
debugging strategy was to delete every
single line of code that generates a
syntax error because it was a good way
to garrulous and so that wasn't a good
strategy so in in in machine learning as
well they're good and less good
debugging strategies right um so let's
not so motivating example uh let's say
building an anti spam classifier and
let's say you've carefully chosen a
small set of hundred words to use as
features so instead of all using you
know ten thousand or fifty thousand
words you've chosen a hundred words that
you think could be most relevant to
anti-spam and let's say you start off
implementing logistic recognization I
think when talked about this is also you
know there's a frequencies in Beijing in
school but you can think of
basing logistic regression where you
have the maximum likelihood term on the
left and then that second term is the
regularization term right so that's so
that's Bayesian logistic regression if
you are Bayesian or which is regression
with regularization if you're you know
using frequency statistics and let's say
that they're just regression with
regularization or based on Lynch's
direction it gets twenty percent test
error which is an unacceptably high
making one in five mistakes on on your
spam filter and so what do you do next
um now for this scenario I want a and so
um for when you implement an algorithm
like this what many teams will do is try
improving the algorithm in different
ways so what many teams will do is say
oh yeah I remember you know well we like
big data more data always help so let's
get some more data and hope that solves
the problem
so one some teams will say let's get
more training examples good and it's
actually true you know more data pretty
much never hurts it almost always holds
but but the key question is how much um
or you could try using a smaller set of
features behind your features Prarie
somewhere in that relevance so let's get
rid of some features or you could try
having a larger cell features kinds of
features that seem small resourceless
add more features um or you might want
other designs of the features you know
instead of just using features in the
email body you can use features from the
email header the email header has on not
just a from to subject but also routing
information about what's a set of
service of the internet that the email
took to get to you or you could try
running gradient descent for more
iterations that that you know that never
hurts right pretty usually in self
grading descent let's switch to Newton's
method or let's try a different value
for lambda or always say you know forget
about basically just regression or
logistic regularization let's let's use
two totally different algorithmic in his
or network or something right so what
happens in a lot of teams is someone
will pick one of these ideas kind of a
random it depends on you know what they
happen to read the night before write
about something or the experience on the
last project and sometimes a project and
sometimes your project leader will say
you know we'll pick one of these and
just say let's try that and it's been a
spend a few days or a few weeks trying
that and it may or may not be the best
thing so I think that in in in my team's
machine or any workflow so first if you
actually you and a few others sit down
and brainstorm a list of the things you
could try you're actually already ahead
of a lot of teams because lot of teams
will kind of just by gut feeling right
or the most opinionated person will pick
one of these things at random and do
that but you brainstorm a list of things
and then and then try to evaluate the
different options you're already ahead
of many teams
oh sorry and and and I think the yeah
and I think right you know and then
unless you analyze these different
options it's hard to know which of these
is actually the best options right so um
the most common diagnostic I end up
using in developing learning algorithms
is a bias versus variance diagnostic
right and I think talking about bias and
variance already with a classifier is
highly bias then it tends to under fit
the data so high bias is well you guys
remember this right if if you have a
data set there's like this a highly
biased crossbar and maybe much too
simple and high variance classifies may
be much too complex and some something
in between you know with with trade-off
bias and variance inappropriately right
so those bodies invariance and so it
turns out that one of the most common
Diagnostics
using in pretty much every single
machine learning project is a bias
versus fear instead gnostic to
understand how much of your learning
over this problem comes from bias and
how much of it comes from variance and
and you know i i've had i don't know
they former PhD students right that
learned about bias and variance when do
the india PhD and then sometimes even a
couple years after they graduated from
Stanford and worked you know on more
problems they actually tell me that
their their understanding of bias and
variances continue to deepen right for
many years so there's one of those
concepts this is um if you can system at
the apply they're making much more
efficient and and this is really the
maybe the single most useful to our town
understanding by the variants of
debugging learning algorithms and so
what I'm going to describe is a workflow
where you would run some Diagnostics to
figure out what is the problem and then
try to fix whether problem is and so
just to summarize this this example you
know literature in Arizona have to be
high and you want to and you suspect
promise either high variance or high
bias and so it turns out that there's a
diagnostic that lets you look at your
algorithms performance and try to figure
out if how much the problem is variance
and how much of the problem is biased oh
and I'm gonna say test error but if
you're developing should I really be
doing this with a def said or a
development set rather than a test set
right but so let me let me explain this
diagnostic in greater detail so turns
out that um if you have a classifier
with very high variance then the
performance on the test set or actually
be a better brother practice use the
holdout cross-validation so that the
developer said you see that the error
that you classify has a much a much
lower error on the training set than on
the development set but in contrast if
you have high bias then the training
error and the test error on the deficit
error will go
behind so let me illustrate this with a
picture so this is a learning curve and
what that means is on the horizontal
axis
you're gonna vary the number of training
examples right and when I talked about
bison barians I had a plot where the
horizontal axis was the degree of
polynomial right you for the first order
second order third order fourth order
polynomial in this plots the horizontal
axis is different this number of
training examples and so it turns out
that when you train a learning algorithm
you know the more data you have usually
the better your development set error
your better your test set error right
it's just error usually goes down when
you increase the number of training
examples the other thing the other and
and and let's say that you're hoping to
achieve a certain level of desired
performance you know for business
reasons you like your spam classifier to
achieve a certain level of design
performance and often sometimes design
level performance is to do about as well
as a human can there's a common business
objective depending on your application
but sometimes it could be different
right so you have some your product
manager you know tells you that all you
if you're leading the brother you think
that you need to hit a certain level
target performance in order to be very
useful spam filter so the other plot to
add to this which will help you analyze
bias versus variances support the
training error now once you're happy of
training error is that it increases as
the training set size increases because
if you have only one example right let's
see building a spam classifier and you
have only one training example then any
algorithm you know can fit one training
example perfectly and so if your
training set size is very small the
training set error is usually zero right
because if you have a five training
examples probably you can fit all five
examples perfectly and there's only if
you have a bigger training set that it
becomes harder for the learning
algorithm to fit your training
data that well right oh well in the
linear regression case you have you have
one example yeah you can Phyllis
straight nine two data if you have two
examples you can fit any model pretty
much to the data and have zero training
around there's only if you have a very
large training set that a classifier
like which is regression or linear
regression may have a harder time
fitting all of your training examples so
that's why training error or average
training error averaged over your
training set generally increases as you
increase the training set size so um now
there are two characteristics of this
plot that suggest that if you plot the
learning curves if you see this dis
pattern to suggest that theorem has a
large bias problem right and the two
properties written in the bottom one the
weaker signal the one that's harder to
rely on is that the development set
error or the test set error is still
decreasing as you increase the training
set size so the green curve is still you
know still looks like it's going down
and so this suggests that if you
increase the training set size and
extrapolate further to the right that
the curve would keep on going down this
turns out to be a weaker signal because
sometimes we look at the curve like that
is actually quite hard to tell you have
to extrapolate to the right so if you
double the training set size how much
further would the green curve go down
then she kind of hard to tell so I find
this a useful signal but sometimes it's
been hard to judge you know exactly
where the curve will go of you
extrapolate to the right um the stronger
signal is actually the second one the
fact that there's a huge gap between
your training error and your test set
error or your training or your jeff's
that there would better thing to look at
is actually a stronger signal that um
this particular learning algorithm has
has high variance right because as you
increase the training set size you find
that the gap between training test error
usually closes usually reduces and so
there's no a lot of room for making your
test set error become closer to your
training
and so that's if you see a learning
curve like there's a strong side that um
you have a variance problem okay now
let's look at what the curve what the
learning curve will look like um if you
have a bias problem so this is a typical
learning curve for high bias which is
that's your def set error or your
development cell the holocrons values
and say their test error and you're
hoping to hit a level of performance
like that and your training error looks
like that and so one sign that you have
a high bias problem is that this
algorithm is not even doing that well on
the training set right even on the
training set you know you're not
achieving your desired level of
performance and it's like not learn it
imagine you're looking out from you see
it was like this algorithm has seen
these examples and even for examples the
scene is not doing this was you were
hoping so clearly the algorithms not
fitting the data well enough so this is
a sign that you have a high bias problem
not in the features you're learning or
it was too simple and and the other
signal is that there's a very small gap
between the training under test error
right and you can imagine when you see a
plot like this no matter how much more
data you get right go ahead and
extrapolate to the right as far as you
want you know no matter how much more
data you get no matter how far you
extrapolate to the right of this plot
they read the blue curve the training
error is never gonna come back down to
hit the desired level of performance and
because the test set error is you know
generally higher than your training set
error no matter how much more data you
have no matter how far you extrapolate
to the right the error is never going to
come down to your design level
performance so if you get a training
error and test that error curve that
looks like this you kind of know that
you know while getting more training
data may help right the green curve
could come down like a little bit if you
get more training data the act of
getting more training data by itself
will never get you to where you
to go okay so let's work through this
example so for each of the four bullets
here each of the four first four ideas
fixes either a high variance or a high
bias problem right so let's let's go
through them and and say an Oscar for
the first one
do you think do you think it helps you
fix high bias or high variance
cool all right high variance right Amy
well I say it will say well right anyone
I'll say why yes right yeah right I
guess if you're feeling a very high
order polynomial that we goes like this
if you have more data it will make it
anything up then the warm at least
oscillate so crazy you feel a higher
order polynomial right and um if you
look at the high variance curve wow it's
not latency in my that's all for some
reason
right so this is the high variance plot
and and if you have a learning algorithm
high variance you can hopefully you know
if you extrapolate to the right there is
some hope that the green curve will keep
on coming down so so getting more
training data if you have high variance
which is if you're in this situation it
looks like it could happen
hope this is worth trying great can't
guarantee your work with worth trying oh
I see yes sorry other this is good so
let's see um the curse will look like
this assuming that your training data is
iid right training and death in Texas
are always drawn from the same
distribution there is learning theory
that suggests that in most cases the
being curve should decay as 1 over
square root of M that's the rate that we
should decay until an answer because
some Bayes error that's what the
learning theory says that doesn't make
sense and sometimes and learning
algorithms errors don't always go to
zero right because sometimes they're
sometimes on the data is just ambiguous
oh my god I guess yeah my PhD students
are including on them we do a lot of
work on health care and sometimes you
look in an x-ray it's just blurry and
you could try to make a diagnosis right
is there is there or I show all on ins
working on predicting patients mortality
or what's the chance of someone dying in
the next year or so and sometimes the
local a patient's medical record you
just can't tell right what is you know
will they pass away in the next year or
so or look like x-ray you just can't
tell is there is there a tumor or not
because it's just blurry so learning
others error I don't always tk20 but the
theory says that as M increases should
decay roughly a rate of 1 over square
root of them to what that baseline error
which is which is called Bayes error
which is the best that you could
possibly hope anything could do given
how blurry the images are
giving home nobody see the day tourists
right all right um oh sorry gave the
eyes their way okay so try small Estella
features that fixes a high variance
problem right and one concrete example
would be if you have this data set and
you're fitting uh you know tenth order
polynomial and the curve all sleeves off
of the place that's high variance you
could say well maybe I don't need a
tenth order polynomial may be actually
use you only Wow sorry what's going on
okay right so maybe you say maybe I
don't need my features to be all of
these things ten for the pollen you you
know maybe if this is too high bearings
and get rid of a lot of features and
just use you know much smaller number of
features right so that fixes high
variance and then if you use the largest
set of features faces high bias right
cool right so that's if you are setting
a straight line to the data there's not
doing that well in go G maybe actually
add a quadratic term and just add more
features right so that fixes values and
having email header features yep January
I would try this if they try to reduce
bias right and so in the workflow of how
you develop a learning algorithm I would
recommend that you yes so so one of the
things about building learning
algorithms is that for a new application
problem it's difficult to know in
advance if you're gonna run into high
bias or high variance problem right it
is actually very difficult to know in
advance what's gonna go wrong with your
learning algorithm and so the advice I
tend to give is if you work on the new
app
Kayson implements a quick and dirty
learning algorithm it have a quick and
dirty implementation of something so you
can run your learning algorithm just you
know sort of logistic regression it
starts with something simple and then
run this bias-variance type of analysis
to see sort of what went wrong and then
use that to decide what to do next you
go to more complex algorithms you try
any more theater the one exception to
this is if you're working on a domain in
which you have a lot of experience right
and so for example you know I've done
the long work on speech recognition so
because I've done that work I kind of
have a sense of how much they just need
it for a new application then then I
might just build something more
complicated from the get-go over here
doing all your working on say face
recognition and because you've rid of
all the research papers you have a sense
of how much data sneed it then maybe
it's worth trying something because
you're building on the body of knowledge
but but if you work on something on a
brand new application that you and maybe
you know no one in the published
academic literature has worked on or you
don't totally trust the published
results to be representative of your
problem then I would usually recommend
that you implement a build a quick and
dirty implementation look at the buyers
and barons of the algorithm and then use
that to better decide what to try next
so I think bias and variance is I think
as that is really like the single most
powerful - I know you know for analyzing
the performance of learning algorithms
that do this pre-emergent every single
machine or any application there's one
other pattern that I see quite often
which is which which edges the second
set which is which is a which is your
optimization algorithm working so so let
me most let me explain this with most
being example right so um it turns out
that when you implement a learning
algorithm you often have a few guesses
for what's wrong
and if you can systematically test if
that hypothesis is right before you
spend a lot of work to try to fix it
then you can be much more efficient so
let's explain that with a concrete
example so you understand those words I
just said maybe they're a little bit
abstract which is let's say that you
know you tune your logistic regression
the algorithm for a while
and let's say the suni Russian gets two
percent error on spam email and 2% error
on non step right and it's okay to have
two percent error on spam email maybe
right you know so you have to read a
little bit of spam email it's like you
that's okay but two percent error on
non-stem it's just not really acceptable
because you're losing one in fifty
important emails and let's say that you
know your teammate right also try chains
in SVM and they find in an SVM using a
linear kernel guess ten percent error on
spam but 0.01 percent error on non-stem
right maybe not great but for this
purpose of illustration let's say this
is susceptible um but because it turns
out logistic regression is more
computationally efficient and and and it
may be easier to update right here you
get more examples to run a few more
iterations of gradient descent and let's
say you want to ship a logistic
regression implementation rather than
SVM implementation so what do you do
thinks it turns out that one common
question you have when training your
learning algorithm is you often wonder
is your optimization algorithm
converging right so you know it's great
in a sense it is it converging and so
one thing you might do is draw a plot of
the training optimization objective of J
of theta or whatever you're maximizing
all along likelihood that J of theta or
whatever versus number of iterations and
often the plot will look like that right
and you know the curve is kind of going
up but not that fast
and if you train it twice as long or
even ten times as long will that help
right and again training maybe the
algorithm for more durations it you know
pretty much never hurts
if you regular eyes the algorithm
properly trained me the algorithm longer
you know although almost always helps
right pretty much never hurts but is the
right thing to do to go and burn another
48 hours of you know CPU or GPU cycles
to just train this thing longer in the
hoping works better right maybe maybe
not so is there a is there a systematic
way to tell is there a better way to
tell if you should invest a lot more
time in running the optimization
algorithm sometimes it's just hard to
tell right so um now the other question
that you sometimes wonder so a lot of
where a lot of this iteration of deeper
learning algorithms is smoking which to
learn I was doing and just asking
yourself one of my guess is for what
could be wrong and maybe one of your
guesses is well maybe optimizing the
wrong cost function right so so here's
what I mean um what you care about is
this weight and accuracy criteria you
know we're sort of sum over your def set
or test set of you know weights on
different examples of whether it gets it
right where the weights are higher for
non-standard span because you really
wanna make sure you label non-spam
e-mail correctly right so so maybe
that's the way to accuracy criteria you
care about but for logistic regression
you're maximizing this cost function
right love likelihood - this
regularization term so you're optimizing
J of theta when what you actually care
about is a of theta so maybe our
optimizing the wrong cost function and
then one way to change the cost function
would be to fiddle with the parameter
lambda right that's one way to change
the definition of J of theta another way
to change J of theta is to just totally
change the cost function you're
maximizing like change it to the SVM
objective right oh and then then part of
that also means choosing the appropriate
value for see okay
and so there's a second diagnostic which
I end up using
which is we shall help you tell is the
problem your optimization algorithm in
other words is gradient ascent not
converging or is the problem that you're
just optimizing the wrong function right
and then we'll see two examples of this
is the first example okay um and so
here's the diagnostic that can help you
figure that out so just to summarize
this scenario this um this example this
running example we're using the SVM
Opera homes which is Russian but you
want to deploy this regression let's let
theta SVM but the parameters learned by
an SVM and instead of writing the SVM
parameters as W and B I'm just going to
write the linear SVM as your linear
kernel you know using the logistic
regression parameter ization right so
you have a linear set of parameters and
that's the thing the prrb the parameters
learned by the just aggression right so
it's just yeah regularize which is
russian or basically just in Russian so
you care about weights and accuracy and
and the SVM outperforms basing is just
regression okay so this is one sly
summary of where we are in this example
so how can you tell if the problem is
your optimization algorithm meaning that
you need to run gradient descent longer
to actually maximize J of theta or is
sorry and then right and this is the
what BRR tries to maximize right so so
how these hell we were were two possible
hypotheses we want to distinguish
between one is that the learning
algorithm is not actually finding the
value of theta that maximizes J of theta
or if for some reason great innocent is
not converging so that would be a
problem the optimization algorithm that
J of theta that you know promptly opt
for the problem to be what the
optimization algorithm means that if
only we could have
algorithm that maximizes J of theta we
would do great but for some reason
gradient descent isn't doing well that's
one hypothesis the second hypothesis is
that J of theta is just a wrong function
to be optimizing it's just a bad choice
of cost function that J of theta is too
different from a of theta the maximizing
J of theta doesn't give you you know a
classifier that does well on a of theta
which is what you actually care about
okay any quiz a problem set up I wanna
make sure people understand this this is
race raise your hand if this makes sense
most people okay cool okay good any
questions about this problem set up oh
thank you why not mess myself theta
directly because F theta is non
differentiable so we don't actually have
you know does this indicate a function
so we actually don't we it turns out
maximizing a of theta explicitly is
np-hard but just we just don't have
great algorithms to trying to do that
okay so it turns out there's a
diagnostic you could use to distinguish
between D sub to these two different
problems and here's the diagnostic which
is check the cost function that logistic
regression is trying to maximize so J
and compute that cost function on the
parameters found by the SVM and compute
that cost function on the parameters
found by based on logistic regression
and just see which which value is higher
okay so there are two cases either this
is greater or this is less than equal to
right there just two possible cases so
what I'm going to do is go over case one
and case two corresponding to this
greater than or it's less than equal
then and let's let's see what that
implies so on the next slide I'm going
to copy over this equation right that's
that's just a fact that the SVM does
better then based on logistic regression
on our problem so on the next I'm going
to copy over this first equation and
then we're going to consider
these two cases separately so great -
that would be case one and less than
equal to will be case - okay so let me
copy over these two equations in the
next slide right so that's the first
equation that i just copied over here
and that's this is the greater than this
case one okay so let's see how to
interpret this in case one J of theta
SVM is greater than J of theta be our
right meaning that whatever the SVM was
doing it found a value for theta which
we've written as theta SVM and theta as
VM has a higher value on the cost
function J than theta be wrong but base
in logistic regression was trying to
maximize J of theta right I mean
basically just Russian it's just using
gradient descent to try to maximize J of
theta and so under case one this shows
that whatever the SVM was doing whatever
your buddy
implementing SVM did they managed to
find a value for theta that actually
achieves a higher value of J of theta
then your implementation of base in
logistic regression so this means that
theta prr fails to maximize the cost
function J and and the problem is with
the optimization algorithm okay so this
case one case two again I'm just copying
over the first equation right because
this is just part of our analysis to
spot the problem set up but in case two
is now the second line is now a less
than or equal sign okay so let's see how
to interpret this so under if we look at
the second equation right the less than
equal to sign it looks like J do the
better job than the SVM maximizing jr.
excuse me it looks like basically just
regression did a better job than GSB
maximising junior theater right so you
know you talk based on religious
aggression to maximize jf Theta and by
golly I found it I found the value of
theta does that it found the value that
achieves a higher value of G of theta
than whatever your buddy did using an
SVM implementation so it actually did a
good job trying to find the value of
theta that dries up J of theta as much
as possible but if you look at these two
equations in combination what we have is
that the SVM does worse on the cost
function J but it does better on the
thing you actually care about a of theta
so what these two equations in
combination tell you is that having the
best value the highest value for J of
theta does not correspond to having the
best possible value for a of theta so
tells you that maximizing J of theta
doesn't mean you're doing a good job on
a of theta and therefore maybe J of
theta is not such a good thing to be
maximizing because maximizing it doesn't
actually give you the result you also
really care about so under case two you
can be convinced that J of theta is just
an is not the best function to
maximizing because getting high value of
J of theta it doesn't get your high
value from what you actually care about
and so the problem is with the objective
function of the maximization problem and
maybe we should just find a different
function to maximize okay so um any
questions about this
yeah let me come back to that yeah it's
a complicated answer yeah all right
actually let's do this first um so all
right
for these four bullets does it fix the
optimization algorithm or does it fix
the optimization objective first one
does it fix the optimization algorithm
or does it fix the automation or
objective cool second one oh I don't
know what's wrong with this thing it's
so strange okay right does it fix the
optimization algorithm or fix also an
objective positive right so Newton's
method still looks at the same cost
function J of theta but in some cases it
just optimizes it much more efficiently
um this is a funny one usually you
fiddle with lambda to trade-off bias and
variance things right this is one way to
change the optimization objective
although usually you change lambda so it
just buys in their hands rather than
this right and then trying to use an SVM
right would be one way to totally change
the optimization objective okay so to
answer the question just now sometimes
we find you have the wrong optimization
objective is that there there isn't
always an obvious thing to do sometimes
you have to brainstorm a few ideas that
there isn't always one obvious thing to
try but at least it tells you that that
category of things are trying out
different optimization objectives it's
working well right all right
so let's go through a more complex
example though they'll you know
incorporate some of these what's wrong I
spray my laptop and wonder if life was
so strange this is what I can do
all right oh all right let's go for more
complex example that will illustrate
some of these concepts that we've been
going through and just let you see
another example of these things oh and
and I find that dumb one thing I've
learned as a teacher you know one of the
ways for you to become good at this
right is to go you know working a good
AI group five years right because when
you work on a good AI group for some
several years then you have seen you
know ten projects and that lets you gain
that experience but it turns out that it
takes I don't know depending on what
they are group you work on it it takes
if you work on a different project every
year then in five years I guess you're
working five projects something I
actually don't know or maybe ten
projects or something but one of the
reasons that song in the way I try to
explain this you actually go give
specific scenarios with you this so that
you know my peer sisters and I we spend
actually we spent like many years
working with Stanford autonomous
helicopter but I'm trying to distill the
key lessons down for you so that you
don't need to work on a project for you
know feeis to gain this experience but
to give you some approximation to this
knowledge and maybe twenty minutes where
is the twenty minutes won't give you the
depth of the three years of experience
but have each other
summarize a key lesson so that so you
can learn from experience that others
took years to develop um all right so uh
this helicopter he sits in my office but
but if you go to my office and you know
grab this helicopter and and we asked
you to write a piece of code to make
this fly by yourself use the learning
algorithm to make this slide by yourself
how do you go about doing so so it turns
out a good way to make a helicopter fly
by itself is to use is to do the
following um step one is build a
computer simulator for a helicopter so
you know that's actually a simulator
right like a video game simulator of a
helicopter um the advantage of using you
know say a video game simulator
helicopter is you could travel all
things trash a lot in simulation
you know which is cheap whereas crashing
a helicopter in real life is this is
slightly dangerous and also more
expensive but so step one build a
similar helicopter except to choose the
cost function and for today I'm just
using a relatively simple cost function
which is squared error so you want the
helicopter to fly the position X desired
and your hug copter is dead yeah wanders
off to some other place X so let's use a
squared error to penalize it right when
we talk about reinforcement learning
towards the end of this quarter well why
should go through the same example again
by using the reinforcement or any
terminology you understand is that
slightly in a slightly deeper level and
we'll go over this exact same example
after you learned about reinforcement
learning but we'll just go over a
slightly simplified very simplified
version today and so running reinforce a
learning algorithm and whatever
enforcement learning algorithm does is
it tries to minimize that cost function
J of theta and so you know and so you
learn some set of parameters theta
subscript R L for controlling the
helicopter right and we're talked about
reinforcement learning you know well you
see all this redone with proper
reinforcement learning notation where J
is a reward function theta R is a
control policy and so on but don't worry
about that for now um so let's say you
do this and the resulting controller
right the way you fly the helicopter it
gives much worse performance than your
human pilot you know so the helicopter
wobbles off of the place and then
doesn't quite stay where you were hoping
it will so what do you do next right
well here are some options corresponding
to the three steps above you could work
on improving your simulator it turns out
even today you know we've had
helicopters for what I don't know I
think that having all commercial houses
around 1950 zip or technical trunk also
for many decades now but air flow around
the helicopter is very complicated and
even today they're actually some details
of how air flows are
after the aerodynamics textbook you know
that even aero-astro people write the
explicitly our answer cannot fully
explain so helicopter is incredibly
complicated and there's almost unlimited
Headroom for building better and more
accurate simulators our copter so maybe
you want to do that or maybe you think
the cost function is messed up you know
maybe a square error isn't the best
metric right and it turns out you know
the way a helicopter helicopter has a
tail rotor that blows went to one side
right so yes because the the main rotor
spins in one direction if it only had a
main rotor then the body was spinning in
the opposite direction kind of equal and
opposite reaction
but in 12 right so the main rotor spins
in one direction if it only had the main
rotor the rotor on top and it just spun
that there's a body and her cotton spin
in the opposite direction so that's why
you need a tear altar to blow air down
off to one side to not make it spin the
opposite direction but because of that
it turns out a helicopter staying in
place is actually tilted slightly to a
side because the tail rotor blows air in
one direction so it's pushing you off to
one side so you have to tell you how to
caulked in the opposite direction so the
main role said blows air to one side -
terrible - blows air to the other side
so you actually stay in place
right so how often is actually
asymmetric the definite right is not the
same so so so because of this
complication maybe squared error isn't
the best error because you know you're
your orientation your optimal
orientation is actually not zero right
so so so maybe you should multiply the
cost function or maybe you want to
modify the reinforcement learning
algorithm because you secretly suspect
that your algorithm is not doing a great
job of minimizing that cost function
great that is not actually finding the
value of theta that absolutely minimizes
J of theta so it turns out that each one
of these topics can easily be a PhD
thesis and you could definitely work for
six years on anyone
these topics and the problem is you know
so actually I actually know someone that
wrote a PhD thesis on write improving
helicopter simulator right but the
problem is maybe a helicopter simulator
is good enough and you can spend six
years improving your helicopter
simulator but will that actually get you
there is and you can write and you can
write a PhD season together PhD doing
that maybe but if you go is not just a
very PhD thesis and actually make your
helicopter fly better is that he's not
not totally clear right if that's the
key thing for you to spend time on um so
what I'd like to do is describe to you a
set of Diagnostics that allows you to
use this sort of logical step-by-step
reasoning to debug which of these three
things is what you should actually be
spending time on right so is it possible
for us to come up with a debugging
process to logically reason so to select
one of these things to work on and have
conviction and then be relatively
confident that this is a useful thing to
work all right so here's how we're going
to do it so just to summarize a scenario
right the controller given by theta RL
the false Paulie right so this is how I
would reason through a learning
algorithm right so suppose suppose all
of these things were true suppose that
again corresponding to the three steps
in the previous slide suppose the
helicopter simulator was accurate and
suppose you know the learning algorithm
correctly you know minimizes the cost
function and suppose J of theta is a
good cost function right if all of these
things were true then the learn
parameters should fly well on the actual
helicopter right but it doesn't fire on
the helicopter so one of these three
things is false
and our job as a figure out is its
identified at least one of these three
statements one two or three that is
false because that that lets you sink
your teeth into something that to work
on right and I think to make an analogy
to more conventional software debugging
of a big complicated program and for
some reason your program crashes you're
like the cool downs or whatever if you
can isolate this big complicated program
into one component that crashes then you
can focus your attention on that
component that you know crashes for some
reason and try to find a bug there right
and so instead of trying to look over a
huge codebase if you could do binary
search or try to isolate the problem in
a smaller part of your codebase then you
could focus your debugging efforts on
that padukone page try to figure out why
it crashes and then fix that at first
and after you fix that they might still
crash then there might be a second
problem that we work on but at least you
know that trying to fix the first bug
seems like it seems like a worthwhile
thing to do right so what we're going to
do is come up with a server the gradient
design come over set of Diagnostics to
isolate the problem to one of these
three components okay so the first step
is let's look at how well the algorithm
flies in simulation right so what I said
just now was you ran the algorithm and
it resulted in a set of parameters that
doesn't do well on your actual
helicopter so the first thing I would do
is just check how well does this thing
even do in simulation right and there
are two possible cases if it flies well
in simulation but doesn't do well in
real life then means something's wrong
with a simulator right and it means is
actually worth working on the simulator
because you know if it's already working
well in the simulator I mean what else
could you expect to learn the very force
of learning algorithms
right you know you you told the reporter
learning algorithm to go and fly well in
the simulator because it's just training
simulation it's already doing well in
the simulator so there's not much to
improve on their release is hard to
improve on that but but but if you found
it learning out if you learn the I room
just one simulator but not in real life
then this means that the simulator isn't
matching real life well and so dish that
does strong evidence there's strong
grounds for you to spend some time to
improve your simulator yeah yeah right
is that it just repeats another camera
is it is ever the case that it flies
values away to about one roll life I
wish that happen
very rarely I I think if that happens I
would I would still work on improving
the simulator so there's actually once
an era where that happens it turns out
that when we train this helicopter in
the simulator or really any robot
simulator we often add a lava noise to
the simulator because one lessons of
learn is that if your simulator is noisy
customizers are always wrong right I
mean any digital simulation is only an
approximation in real world so we tend
to have a lot of noise so all of our
simulators because we think that the
learning algorithm is robust so all this
noise you've thrown at it in simulation
then whatever noise the real world
throws at it it has a bigger chance at
being robust to as well and so we tend
to throw a lot of noise into Intel
simulators and so one case where that
does happen is when we find we threw too
much noise on it in simulation and then
that might be a sign we should dial back
the noise a bit
yeah all right cool oh so yeah so this
first I know see tells you should work
on improving simulation but just I think
if there's a big mismatch between
simulation performance and real work
performance that's a good sign that you
know that
improve insulation second um this is
actually very similar to the diagnostic
we use on the spam you know based on
logistic regression as a SVM example so
what we're going to do is we're going to
measure this equation and this is this
again this very similar to our previous
equation which is take the cost function
- similar to previous example take the
cost function J that reinforcement
learning is total minimize right it's JJ
of theta was a squared error right so
take the cost function that
reinforcement learning was total
minimize and see if the human achieves
better squared error than the
reinforcement learning algorithm and
just see you know this human flies
better so let's measure the human
performance on this squared error cost
function and see which one does better
so they're two cases that equation will
be either less than or they'll be
greater than or equal to is there less
law greater than equal to so case one is
say two human is less than sees me J of
theta human is less than J of theta RL
that would be this case then that tells
you that the problem is with the
reinforcement learning algorithm right
that somehow the human achieves a lower
squared error and so the learning
algorithm is not finding the best
possible squared error that is some
other controller as evidenced by
whatever the human is doing that
actually achieves a lower cost function
right so in this case we think the
learning algorithm or the harbor
enforcement learning algorithm is not
doing a good job minimizing that and
what were Connie reinforcement or anyhow
really the other case would be of the
sine inequality is the other way around
right now in this case you can infer
that the problem is in the cost
function because what happens here is
the humanists line better than your
enforcement learning algorithm but the
human is achieving what looks like a
worse cause that your enforcement
learning algorithm so what this tells
you is that minimizing J of theta does
not correspond to flying well right your
learning algorithm achieves a better
value for J of theta you know J of theta
are out is actually smaller than one of
the human is doing so the reinforcement
learning algorithm as far as it knows
this doing a great job because it's
finding a value of theta where J of
theta is really really small but in this
last case you know that finding such a
small value of J of theta doesn't
correspond to flying well off because a
human doesn't achieve such a good value
in the cost function but the helicopter
actually just looks better was flying in
a more satisfactory way and that tells
you that the squared error cost function
is not the right cost function for what
flying after it events right and so um
through this set of Diagnostics you
could decide which one of these three
things improving the simulator improving
in our our algorithm before so learning
algorithm or improving the cost function
is the thing you should work on and what
happens in actually in this particular
project and what often happens in
machine learning applications is you run
the set of Diagnostics and this actually
happened when we're working on this
helicopter we've run the set of
Diagnostics and then one week we were
saying yep simulated score the problem
let's work on that and it would improve
the simulator improves the simulator and
after a couple weeks of work we run
these Diagnostics and say oh it looks
like the simulator is not good enough
and maybe there's a problem with the our
our algorithm then we work on that work
on that improve that and after that
after a while I'll say oh they'll say
that's also good enough and the problem
is in the cost function and sometimes
the the location of the most acute
problem shifts right after you've
cleared out one set of problems it might
be the case that now the ball Oneg is
the simulator right and so I often use
this workflow to constantly drive
prioritization for what to work on next
and and to answer a question just now
about how do you find a new cost
function it turns out find me a new cost
function it is actually not that easy
so as you want one my own former PhD
students Adam coats through this type of
process realize that finding a good cost
function is actually really difficult
because if you want a helicopter to fly
maneuver you're like fire speed and they
make a bank turn right like how do you
math Matthew define what is an accurate
bank determines thank you really
difficult to write down an equation to
specify what is a good way for how to
fly like that and then do a turn it's
just how do you specify what is a good
turn so he wound up writing a research
paper one of the best application paper
more than I see now on how to define a
good cost function it's actually pretty
complicated but the reason he did it and
it was a good use of his time was
running Diagnostics like these which
gave us confidence that this was
actually a worthwhile problem and then
that results in you know making real
progress now about it yeah okay
um any questions about this all right
cool actually I think of all right
anyway all right fun how the to do
so let's not show this is fine yeah you
guys saw some of these earlier all right
so um a long time
all right let's go for this so um in
addition to these specific diagnoses of
bias versus variance and optimization of
the results musician objective
oh sorry and when we do our L I want to
just go through that example one more
time so you see everything we just saw
again after you've learned about
reinforcement learning they turn this
course L okay
now in addition to these type of
Diagnostics how to debug learning
algorithms there's one other set of
tools you find very useful which is
error analysis tools which lets you
figure out which is another way for you
to figure out what's working what's not
working or really what's not working the
learning algorithm so let's let's go
through a multi-beam example um so let's
say you're building a you know like a
security system so when someone walks in
front of a door you unlock the door not
based on whether or not you know that
person is authorized to enter right that
please and so let's say that so they're
longer machine learning applications
where is not just one learning algorithm
right but instead you have a pipeline
that's trained together many different
steps so how do you build a face
recognition algorithm to decide if
someone approaching your front doors
authorized unlock the door right well
here's something you could do which is
you start with a camera image like this
and then um you could do pre-processing
to remove the background so all that
complicated color background let's get
rid of that and it turns out that um
when you have a camera against a static
background right you could actually do
this you know what a little bit of noise
be relatively easy because if you have a
fixed camera that's just like mounted
you know on your doorframe it always
sees the same background and so you can
just look at what pixels have changed
and and just keep the pixels that have
changed compared to I mean right because
you know this camera always sees that
gray background and
some Brown bench in the back and so just
look at what pixels have changed the
login and does that's background remove
all right so business this this is this
is actually feasible back just looking
at what pixels have changed and keeping
the pixels they've changed relative
today
and so after getting to the background
you could run the face detection
algorithm and then after detecting the
face it turns out actually you know I've
actually worked a bunch of face
detection told a bunch of face face
recognition systems it turns out that
for some of the leading face recognition
systems someone depends on details with
some of them it turns out that the
appearance of the eyes is a very
important cue for recognizing people
this is why if you cover your eyes a
much all the time recognizing
people as eyes are very distinct were
people just segment out the eyes
segments the nose and not the same you
send out the know it's Halloween and
then and then feed these features into
some other algorithm say which is
Russian that then you know finally
outputs a label that says is this the
person right that that you know you're
authorized to open the door for um so it
so in many learning algorithms you have
a complicated pipeline like this of
different components that that have to
be strung together and you know if you
read the newspaper articles about or if
you read research papers in machine
learning often the research papers will
say oh we build a machine translation
system where you train down gazillion
you know sentences found on the internet
and it does great and a pure end-to-end
system so there's like one learning
algorithm that sucks in an input like
suck on an English sentence and spit on
the French sentence or something right
so this that's like one learning
algorithm it turns out that for a lot of
practical applications if you don't have
a gazillion examples you end up
designing
much more complex machine learning
pipelines like this where it's not just
one monolithic learning algorithm but
instead there are many different smaller
components and I think in I think that
you know the
I think that having a lot of data is
great right I love having more data but
big data has also been a little bit
overhyped and a lot of things you could
do with small data sets as well and in
the teams I work with we find that if
you have a relatively small D that's
that often you can still get great
results you know my team's often get
great results with 100 images a hundred
change examples something but when
you're a small data it often takes more
insightful design about machine learning
pipelines like this know we have a
machine learning pipeline like this the
things you want to do one thing you want
to do is so so you you build the
pipeline like this and it doesn't work
right there's this common workflow you
build a pipe build something doesn't
work so you want to debug it so in order
to decide which part of the pipeline to
work on is very useful if you can look
at your the error of your system
and try to attribute the error to the
different components so you can decide
which component to work on X right and
and there's a here I'll tell you true
story you're the pre process background
removal step right since you're getting
rid of the background it turns out that
there are a lot of details of how to do
background removal for example the
simple way to do it is to look at every
pixel and just see which pixels have
changed oh but it turns out that if
there's a tree in the background that
you know waves a little bit because the
wind moves the tree and blows the leaves
and branches around a little bit then
sometimes the background pixels do
change a little bit and so they're
actually really complicates a background
removal algorithms they tried to model
basically the trees and the bushes
moving around a little bit in background
so you know that even though the pixels
of the tree roos around this part of the
background is just still get rid of it
so background removal there's simple
versions where you just look at each
pixel and see how much has changed and
they're incredibly complicated versions
so I actually know someone that was
trying to work on a problem like this
and they decided to improve
background removal algorithm and they
actually does this per person actually
literally wrote a PhD theses on
background removal and so I'm glad you
got a PhD but it turned but you know
when I look at the problem he was
actually trying to solve I don't think
it actually moved in you know right so
so this one I suspected the American I
so laws you know you can still publish a
paper and and it was technically
innovative I was thanking very good
technical work but but but but if so
there you go suppose you favor great do
that but there goes to build a better
face recognition system then I would
carefully ask which components should
you actually spend your time to work all
right um so yes what you can do with
error analysis which is say your overall
system has eighty five percent accuracy
it's what I would do I would go in and
in your depth set and your development
said to hold our cross-validation settle
right go in and for every one of your
examples in the DEF set I would plug in
the ground truth for the background
meaning that rather than using a some
you know approximate heuristic algorithm
for roughly cleaning out the background
which may or may not were that well I
would just use Photoshop and for every
example in the Deaf said I would give it
the perfect background removal right so
imagine if instead of some noisy harbor
I'm trying to remove the background this
step of the algorithm was just had
perfect performance right and then you
could give it perfect performance on
your depth set on your test set just by
using Photoshop to just tell it this is
a background this is the foreground
right and let's say that when you plug
in this perfect background remove all
the accuracy improves to eighty five
point one percent and then you can keep
on going from left to right in this pat
pipeline which is now instead of using
some learning algorithm to do face
detection this just go in and for the
test set
you know modify kind of have the face
detection algorithm cheat right having
just memorized it right
location for the face and the test seven
just give it a perfect result in the
test set so when I shade in these things
that means I'm giving a perfect result
right so let's just go in and on the
test set give it the perfect face
detection for every single example and
and then look at the final output and
see how that changes the accuracy of the
final output right and then same for
these components I segmentation no
segmentation most segmentation and then
and you do this one at a time and then
finally for let's just regression if you
give it the perfect output you know your
your accuracy should be a hundred
percent right so now what you can do is
look at the sequence of of steps and see
which one gave you the biggest gain and
it looks like um in this example it
looks like when you gave it perfect face
detection the accuracy improved from
eighty five point one to ninety one
percent so roughly a six percent
improvement and that tells you that if
only you can improve your face detection
algorithm maybe your overall system
could get better by as much as six
percent so this gives you faith that you
know maybe it's worth improving on your
face detection component and in contrast
just tells you that even if you had
perfect background removal it's only 0.1
percent better so maybe don't don't
don't spend too much time on that and it
looks like that when you gave it perfect
eye segmentation it went up another four
percent so maybe that's another good
project to prioritize right um and if
you're in a team one common structure
would be to do this type of analysis and
then have some people work on face
detection some people work on our
segmentation you could usually do a few
things in parallel if you have a large
area team but at least this should give
you a sense of the relative position of
the different things this question
Yeah right so if you just cumulatively
sighs just give a perfect eye
cementation then add on top perfect no
segmentation or do you give a perfect
eye segmentation and then take that away
and then give it perfect no segmentation
um the way I presented it here is done
cumulatively and and it turns out that
uh let's see if you give it once you
give it perfect face uh once you give it
you know perfect things in the later
stages maybe the earliest stages doesn't
matter that much anymore so that's one
pattern but it turns out that you could
do it either way right for the eyes nose
mouth you could do it cumulatively or
one at a time and you'll probably get
relatively similar results no guarantee
you might get different results in terms
of conclusions but but I think to the
extent that you are wondering if doing a
cumulative Leivers is not a cure to you
might give you different results I would
just do it both ways and then and then
and then I think these um error analysis
is not hard mathematical rule if that
makes sense it's not that you do this
and then there's a form that that tells
you okay work on face detection right I
think that this should be married with
judgments on you know how hard do you
think it is to improve face detection
versus my segmentation right but this at
least gives you a sense of it gives you
a sense of privatization and it's worth
doing this in multiple ways if if you
think that if you're concerned I'm a
discrepancy in accumulative in
documented versions um so when you have
a complex machine learning pipeline this
type of error analysis helps you break
down the error to attribute the error to
different components which lets you
focus your attention on what to work on
Oh ready yeah if your face insertion
accuracy and then you're Eric jumps what
is that anything um it's not impossible
for that to happen it would be quite
rare
I will so at the high level what I would
do is go in and try to figure out what's
going on actually I wouldn't ignore that
so this is another thing I see sometimes
the team gets a discovers a weird
phenomena like that and they just ignore
and they move on I wouldn't do that I
would is actually go whenever you find
one of these weird things
I wouldn't gloss over the lurid I would
go in and figure out what's going on
this make sense it's like debugging
software you know if you are if you're a
chunk debugger piece of software and if
whenever you move your mouse over you
know some button some random pixel color
changes you go home that's weird and
then some people just ignore it and say
oh well the user won't see this so what
you're saying is quite rare but not
impossible but I would I would I don't
have an easy solution for how to figure
out what's going on but I would I would
want to figure out what's going on all
right so one last thing before we break
so error analysis helps figure out the
difference between where you are now 85%
overall system accuracy and 100% right
so it tries to explain difference
between where you are and you know
perfect performance there's a different
type of analysis called ablative
analysis which figures out the
difference between where you are and
something much worse so so here's what I
mean um so let's say that you built on
less heat build a good anti-spam
crossfire by adding lots of clever
features so this is a Russian right so
you know spelling correction because
families tried to misspell words to mess
up the tokenizer
to make words not you know spammy was
not look like spam
send the host features what machines
email come from Eva Heather features you
could have a parser from NLP pasta text
use JavaScript pauses understand write
or even couldn't fetch the webpages to
know that email refers to and pause that
and the question is how what the ditch
these components really hope and it
turns out if you're writing a research
paper you know sometimes you rather use
me to say hey look I build a great spam
classifier and that's okay that's like a
nice result to have but if you can
explain to your reader either in a
research paper or or in a class project
report like a term project what what
actually made a difference that conveys
a lot of insight as well so um so say
simple which is Russian whether all
these clever features got ninety four
percent performance and with all of your
addition of all these clever features
you've got ninety nine percent accuracy
so in ablative analysis what you would
do is remove the components one at a
time to see how it breaks right so
Justin so just now we were adding to the
system by making components perfect with
error analysis is how it improves here
we're gonna remove things one at a time
did not mean to remove that to figure
out what's going on with PowerPoint all
right remove things one at a time to see
how it breaks so lets you remove
spelling correction and as a set
features the error goes down like that
then let's remove the center host
features room with email header features
and so on until when you remove all of
these features you end up there and
again you could do this cumulative lee
or the roof one and put it back we want
to put back you know you could do it
both ways and see if they give you
slightly different insights and so the
conclusion from this peculiar analysis
is that the biggest gap is from the text
positive features because when you
remove that the error the accuracy went
down by four percent
so you know this is strong evidence oh
you want to publish a paper you can say
write text positive features sick of
weekly improves spam filter accuracy and
then that level of insight and then if
you're working on the spam filter for
many years right you know they're
they're out there there are really
important applications where sometimes
the same team will work on for many
years
so this types of error analysis gives
you intuition about what's important and
what's not and helps you decide to maybe
even double down on to expose the
features or maybe ever or maybe a
dissent the host features as to
competition expensive to compute tells
you maybe just get rid of that then
without too much harm but and also if
you're publishing paper or sending a
report this gives much more insight into
your replicates okay all right
um so that's it for error analysis and
if later analysis I hope this was useful
real class projects as well take one
last question oh right
oh yeah how are you - zo there was no
systematic way if you can have a
systematic way you do that the other way
to non-cumulative would remove one
coming back when you might put it back
so either way it works
alright let's break and problem set who
is due tonight a friendly reminder and
prom said three will be posted in the
next like several tens of minutes okay
thanks everyone